لبانكو المركزي والعراقيه وسماحه لمزيد من
المصارف ببيع الدولار لاغراض السفر
والعلاج والدراسه في خطوه لوقف صعود دولار
مقابل الدينار العراقي ولسيطره على اسعار
تداوله الرسميه
تراجع مقابل الدولار حيث بلغ سعر صرف
الدولار الواحد الاسبوع الماضي نحو
1590 دينارا عراقيا في حين يبيع البنك
المركزي العراقي الدولار ب 1460 دينار
في بلادي تسبب بموجات انتقادات شعبيه
وسياسيه كبيره بعد ان اثر على شريحه واسعه
من العراقيين وخاصه اصحاب الدخل المحدود
عدم الاستقرار في سعر الدينار العراقي
زائد الدولار الامريكي بدا في ديسمبر من
العام الماضي عندما اعلنت حكومه مصطفى
الكاظمي رفعه سعر الدولار من 1170 دينارا
الى الفا و 450
اعاده سعر السعر الى ما كان عليه في ضوء
ارتفاع اسعار النفط في السوق العالميه
بتخفيض سعر الدولار وترك الامر في عهده
البنك المركزي العراقي وفي الايام الماضيه
سجلها سعر الدولار ارتفاعا جديدا ووصل الى
1,590 دينار عراقيا بالرغم من ارتفاع
احتياطاته من العمله الاجنبيه الى مستويات
قياسيه
العراق
على اليات حمايه القطاع المصرفي والزبائن
والنظام المالي حسب تعبيره
ينضموا الينا من بغداد مراسلنا سامر يوسف
سامر هذا القرار للبنك المركزي السماحه
ببيع الدولار الى اي مدى يتوقع ان يحتوي
الموقف ويحسن وضع الدينار العراقي
العمله الصعبه مقابل الدينار العراقيه
التي تشهدبا خلال الفتره الماضيه وحتى هذا
اليوم البنك المركزي العراقي كان قد اوقف
ما كان يعرف بمزاد بيع العمله وهو مزاد
يومي تباع من خلاله العمله الصعبه اي
دولار تحديدا
للمصارف وهمم الشركات بشكل يومي او وقف
هذا المزاد ليعمل على همم منصه الكترونيه
هي من تتحكم ببيع هذه العمله بيع الدولار
وبمم نسب اقل من السابق ما تسبب بهذا
الارتفاع ومن ثم التذبذب بهذا همم السعر
اليوم صباحا كان السعر همم يختلف عن ما هو
عليه الان همم تحديدا نحن هنا في مركز
همم المكاتب مكاتب الصيره في بغداد في
منطقه الحارثي هو المركز الاكبر في جانب
همم الكرخ هنا احد مكاتب همم الصراف
نتحدث مع ابو عبد الله همم ابو عبد الله
كيف كان سعر الصرف صباح اليوم كيف هو الان
هل هناك
فرق الصبح كان همم سعر الصرف ب 147 و200
وحاليا همم 148 ونصف
147 او 157 و 200 العفو حاليا 158 ونصف
هذه المره الاولى التي يرتفع فيها الدولار
امام الدينار ام ماذا ما هي مراحل ارتفاع
الدولار
الي وصل هذا سعر الصرف ما يقارب
عندما غيروه بسنه ال 2010 من 148 الى 1200
هذه المره الاولى يوصل الى هذه الاسعار
زين
صارت صارت رده فعل عند المواطن يعني اصبح
السعر همم
استثناعي يعني ما واصل الاتصال لفتره 12
سنه 10 سنين
هل تاثر الاقبال اقبال المواطنين على شراء
الدولار
لان السعر عالي جدا
ويعني كل ما يراجع الزبونه والمواطن
ينصدموا بهذه الاسعار يعني طفره جدا سريعه
خلال هذه الايام اللي تقريبا صار لها شهر
او اقل
المراحل او الفترات التي يتغير فيها
الدولار في اليوم الواحد
متقلبه متقلبه وسريعه
متقلبه وسريعه
شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا جزيلا لك مريم هذا
الامر ولد ردود فعل لدى المواطنين وايضا
غضب خصوصا وان غالبيه البضائع في البلد
هنا تستورد من الخارج ما يعني بان اسعار
هذه البضائع قد ارتفعت همم بعض المواطنين
هنا يتحدثون عن ارتفاع هذه الاسعار في
السوق المحليه المواد الغذائيه وكل المواد
التي يتم استيرادها من الخارج بسبب ارتفاع
الدولار